this is
this is a normal family uh you know we
were defending
will smith and saying oh he's not weird
with this kid and then this was
well let's just watch this this is will
smith jaden's 21st birthday party
we're gonna shoot by the way i want to
point out
14 million views i just want to point
something out too right
youtube rewind you notice how it's like
they're youtubers now man
oh yeah they're just they're youtube
it's the him and jack black oh yeah
we don't we don't need [ __ ] we don't
need keemstar around here
we don't need these [ __ ] we don't
need all you uh people who built youtube
sticking around and [ __ ] this place
up yeah
it's will smith now we have a drink
together tonight
really the first legal drink
videos monetized by the way 14 million
views 6.1 million subscribers
he's making a lot of money on here
yeah well this party was paid for uh by
youtube
who thinks filming it you you think that
you think that will smith hired a film
no no no no no no this is youtube sent
film crew to film it i i
would put you all the money in there
well you know also too you're gonna
notice
other things throughout this video such
as okay
nobody in the family is actually
grilling no the burgers are done
like everything is just is there
hollywood hollywood family life like
there's no
like even if you have money right even
if you're like
success like certain birthday party
don't you want to be like hey we're
going to grill we're going to hang out
i'm going to [ __ ] grill i'm going to
make i'm going to do i'm putting an
apron on yeah like you know it's just
like that you bring the [ __ ] bring
the slaves out to make me burgers
together tonight really uh-oh
the first lego drink you've had rather
than all of the times
wait you've had many illegal drinks i'm
sorry youtube
are you verifying and promoting underage
drinking on your platforms
okay if it's degeneracy it's fine it's
fine
remember we had our first drink with him
in europe i'm not talking about
sometimes
[Music]
by the way can i just point something
out that i was really loving about this
video these people
hate each other oh yeah oh yeah no they
don't like each other at all this is a
business this is a brand
yeah this man hates his wife
this man this this his wife hates him
it's all [ __ ] up ninja guinea sent in
by north spot didn't say anything but
thank you so much
i'm here so i could record but i felt
like that was taking it far no that
would have been hot though i can still
have him come
to report for your birthday yeah
good idea yeah yeah that would be hot
yeah
it's so staged like we're having a whole
thing here
this is really awkward awesome so
they're now going to take over
irl oh yeah oh no absolutely with with
pre-recorded
jack black will smith [ __ ] yeah
absolutely so tight
so much fun so much fun 21st going crazy
i was going to say he looks like he has
this is awesome i went surfing already
any day that you go surfing it's it's a
good one you oh
the only way the only time you see black
surfers if the dads are rich like
there's no black surfers in in natural
habitats
so it was already good we're not surfing
ouch that's how the table's hot the
table's out oh and you can also play
copyright music
behind it's fine content
[Music]
son's friend okay oh he should've
why is he okay 21 year old birthday
party
it's a part of the disrespect a
sacrifice
for y'all over and over you feel like
because of the sacrifice
why is he wearing focus there's a couple
things that are going on here
why why is jayden wearing little shorty
shorts like like little daisy dukes
because he's you know
he's a fan because of the second one
yes
come on dude it's totally hold on no no
no no no no i'm sorry just something i
noticed
he just pays a random dude to stand
there in short shorts and play guitar
yeah that's normal
do these these people think no no no i'm
sorry
do they think they're endearing
themselves with everyday people when
they do this
hey i'm a dad just like you is that what
is that having a little birthday party
like anyone
is that is that what they think they're
doing wait do you have you never rented
a malibu mansion for one day with a with
a
with a mirror pool no we're looking for
an infinity pool no i haven't uh
that's what's called infinity pool while
some dude plays spanish guitar with his
dick hanging out of his short shorts
you've never done that no i've never
done this
with your wife who used to [ __ ] tupac
shakur and also you who used to [ __ ]
tupac shakur and your son that 4chan
says you
for years
[Music]
see that white hand by the way i want to
put it on smith that was can you look at
the very obvious
white hand by the way what appears to
possibly be a white
female hand and i could be wrong there
could be a male but
jada yeah come here you got to help us
with this problem
we have a problem no that's how the
human mind does we're having a totally
normal
everyday people party for my son's 24.
yeah i remember when i was 21 and i had
a party with my
with my family and we would just sit by
about a clear balcony and drink scotch
how much do you think that costs to rent
to rent because that's a rental
they don't live there that's definitely
a rental that probably
costs
probably i would say 10 gs a day a day i
have 10 g's a day
because it's like a panoramic view
that's a 360 view
around the ocean probably in malibu like
you said you get the infinity pool
the whole thing is just the only people
who rent this
are will smith and porn companies that's
exactly
and even when the porn company rents it
they're banging out like 15.
yeah they're like nope get in and out in
and out in and out let's go
i gotta make this money back no problem
your mind makes one so it has something
to do
hey babe hey i was just saying that
everybody's really handsome again we're
just regular folks and i feel like they
get girls too
easy right because they have they didn't
have to suffer the way
i did get ready for more endearing every
man talk get ready for it
you weren't into me i had work to do but
you had a lot of other bad
joints that were very much into you i
was i'm talking about at their age when
i was like
baby
i'm gonna give her credit that is true
he's trying to talk like when i was
their age yeah
you were the fresh prince of bel-air
when you were their age yeah but they
were also
i'm laughing because the way she
sandbags they don't like each other oh
no i don't know i hate each other
absolutely
his bug man son like what happened he
just just didn't die his hair he dyed
his eyebrows too
it isn't i'm very proud of you young man
here's how this all here this drink is
fully done
it's over johnny bro it's just a regular
youtube vid
we're just hanging out with the smith
family they're just like us
14 million views
i know i'm sorry just a couple more
minutes i know we're a little bit
overweight i i hadn't seen this before
mike sent this to me
this is the stuff that in great you're
right man they're just
youtube rewi i bet you i bet you he's
getting ad revenue
there's a lot look he's getting paid out
of pocket
here just please come on please will
smith please and then we'll even
monetize your video we'll pay you twice
that's what's going on
it's over johnny
yeah oh youtube's over johnny
hey jaden i got somebody else coming for
your birthday and then you just see him
skittle wow oh no it's a crossbowman's
self
what's up what's wrapping rainbow [ __ ]
losing yeah this kid's like hi i'm jack
black's kid and jaden's like gonna suck
sucky dad said i had to say yes to you
because you were bigger stars
i'm gonna keep it real i'm gonna keep it
real right now cause i
i've kept what a
weird looking kid man weird look weird
laugh
everything that's a that's by the way
i'm not
accusing will smith of anything but just
looking at jaden
somebody did something to this [ __ ]
kid you think so
that's not a norm that that's that's
like the sound of silence playing as i
look at this
dude you're right you know what i mean
from saying this
i've kept from saying this since you
were born
most of the decisions okay okay
that developed you were your mother your
mother
oh the other thing that by the way will
smith so this is he's doing fake drunk
he's not actually drunk but he's not
good at it he's not good he's not he's
doing fake drunk
he's doing a fake laugh will smith's
doing fake drunk
everything in this is manufactured we're
having fun we're shoving buddies
14 million
views
was felt the whole time
[Music]
are they getting into their normal cars
this is all just very normal
very normal all right we got to wrap up
i'm sorry i could honestly
watch this whole thing and be angry but
this is what will smith does now like he
did he probably makes more money doing
this than making movies at this point
right
i mean what's the last big will smith
movie
wild wild west kidding um what was the
bright the one he did with this kid that
was terrible right no no that was the
nephilim netflix one about the orcs